welcome to the Grayson Tim show all
right welcome to one silver Wednesday I
named it that way yeah are you sure cuz
that's gonna stick for a long time yeah
wonderful instead it's gonna be called
Oh Oh W owl okay Oh God as it goes we're
really effeminate cow the golden globes
are coming up and Tim and I haven't seen
any of the movies nominated I don't
think I have I don't think I have either
yeah but we decided that's perfect for
us to review all of the movies that are
numbered for this picture
so in gold lips is actually two
categories for Best Picture there's
drama and then there's musical or comedy
Oh God just hand movies there's ten
movies you just want to do drama or just
click I think we do move let's do both
and we'll do these as like brief reviews
what are we starting with
well here's a slave Charlie oh no nope
next captain Phillips captain Phillips
um it was like the serial Captain Crunch
meets Captain Kirk
it was delicious and authoritative what
did you think of it three out of five
why I don't know give us a reason Hey
doesn't mean reason why some other
pirates picked up captain Phillips no is
that what happened yeah
hey it's the thing with Tom Hanks do
remember the Marines killed the fire
they got the I assume it's that exact
retelling I just kept in crunchyroll
hurt your mouth so much uh cuz it's
delicious gravity gravity that movie
really weighed on me anetha is a very
interesting for hour-long derivation of
Newton's laws dad a stove
it's Clooney great but even in a
spacesuit Philomena hated it awful I
liked it
philomene - not making that movie
shouldn't made it terrible waste of
money I don't think it's more like
filament - no rush
it was too hurried crippling tale of a
sorority although I appreciated yeah the
look at the Canadian rock band in your
my fan club rush no God the music a
musical comedy American hustle Jennifer
Lawrence tits for days okay Bradley
Cooper flew the Cooper house it's fun
tips for days is fine if I make a cute
Bradley Cooper
he's really friendly cute for her hurry
up and get me out of this movie am i
right no he loved it wet inside Llewyn
Davis yeah this is an interesting movie
that's what he said because it was two
hours of live surgery oh can find it on
TLC oh good for TLC to get a nomination
that's good for them yeah Nebraska oh I
didn't see this too much corn
too much cohort not enough corn it's
very polarizing feel the wolf of Wall
Street huh woof that Leonardo DiCaprio
oh you know this is actually a sequel to
Teen Wolf yeah it's when he grows up and
becomes a businessman yeah but what the
businessmen don't know is that he's a
wolf and so what were the audience is
supposed to imagine our mind is it worse
that he works in Wall Street is it worse
he's a wolf I know you don't know you
don't know it asks the hard-hitting
questions makes you think are we done
okay well that's it for Tim and graces
reviews have all of the Golden Globe
nominees I let us know what you thought
about the movies or don't I don't care
yeah
how do I in my videos ooh I don't know
um mom my mom is dancing off camera
stuffing a stage mom right now I'm gonna
fall okay let I'm gonna follow in your
moves
go ahead twists
I read bringing up base runner home
right